it's an exciting day for everyone
donning that cap and gown in person
after a while of that distance learning
madison kimbra joins us live from sam
boyd stadium tonight with more
madison yeah sasha many students lost
the opportunity to graduate with their
peers in 2020 but today
take a look
you can see students friends and family
are gathering around to celebrate
csn's 2021 graduate students are
arriving now
as the ceremony begins at 6 30.
preparation for today's event started at
noon today
and since then they have turned the
football field here at sam boyd stadium
into a beautiful graduation venue with
white chairs lining the field and
flowers and balloons
now in the last decade csn has seen more
than 25 thousand students earn their
degree in certificates
we spoke to the first graduate to arrive
today who was graduating with his
associates of arts degree
and eventually plans on attending unlv
for film he shares what this day means
to him
i'm the first of my family to go to
college
and it really means a lot that i that i
had the opportunity to go early
and officially go after high school
and worked for my degree
several parents and family members have
already arrived and now graduates are
waiting in line like you saw under the
white tents
more than a thousand students rsvp'd to
the graduation and the ceremony
is expected to last for several hours
temperatures will be checked upon
arrival and masks are required for
everyone attending
and you know when talking to school
officials earlier they said there's
going to be a special surprise at the
end of the ceremony so we will look out
for that a surprise for the students and
staff
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now